in the year 412 the roman empire had
been split into two portions for more
than a century and currently each side
was ruled by an emperor descended from
theodosius the great who had declared
christianity the only religion of the
empire
the eastern portion of the empire was
centered in the great city of
constantinople where the imperial family
governed from its massive complex of
palaces that overlooked the bosphorus
walled off from the rest of the city
here in this corner of wealth and
privilege emperors expected to rule with
the blessings of god and enjoy the
wealth and power that flow to this city
that seemed the center of the christian
and civilized world
however in the year 412 the theodosian
dynasty was in trouble
emperor arcadius had died in 408 when
his heir theodosius ii was only seven
years old
and in the intervening years powerful
men began to vie for the throne occupied
by the boy
the dynasty would be saved by the
actions of pulkaria
emperor arcadius's teenage daughter
in this lecture i will show how she took
power and established a christian reign
in this opulent palace
that would be enough to make her
interesting but she did more she changed
the way christians for the next
millennium would venerate the virgin
mary
let's begin with how this fearless girl
took power
right after arcadius death the palace
was governed by the head palace eunuch
antiochus who took charge of the orphan
theodosius and his sisters bulkaria
arcadia flasala and marina
antiochus dutifully saw to the education
of the children but he could not protect
them from the politics that surrounded
the royal court
there were many who thought to gain
power by taking advantage of the young
children
in 412 however things changed
pulkaria was 13 years old and though
it's hard to believe this enterprising
child took over
she persuaded her younger brother the
titular emperor to fire antiochus and
she took personal charge of the imperial
family
a chronicler described her actions with
admiration writing she took control of
the government reaching excellent
decisions and swiftly carrying them out
with written instructions
he further reported that society at
large
called her the emperor's guardian
she would serve as regent for a few
years until theodosius reached the age
of 15 and she continued to serve as his
main advisor for the rest of their lives
the young girl was highly religious
when her grandfather theodosius the
great had established the roman catholic
church as the only permitted religion he
united religion and rule
with his action
people believe that god was on the side
of the house of theodosius
and his family claimed to rule with
god's blessing
bulgaria took this association seriously
the idea that god supported the
theodosian dynasty helped the women of
the house of theodosius rule because
they ruled by the blessing of god
not by the strength of their military
power
the coins the women of this family
commissioned to be struck are beautiful
propaganda pieces
the coins show pool carrier dressed in
royal gowns with the hand of god at the
top of the coin bestowing his blessing
by crowning her
bulkaria used her religious beliefs to
consolidate power for her and her
brother
she took a vow of virginity and imposed
the same vow on her sisters
this was no private resolution no she
did it publicly she went to the great
church in constantinople the church of
the holy apostles and dedicated an altar
covered with gold and precious jewels
she ordered that her vow of virginity be
inscribed on the altar and she did it a
chronicler wrote on behalf of her own
virginity and her brother's rule
a church historian of the period sozoman
wrote that this remarkable event was
guided by god to ensure that bulgaria
would be the protector of her brother
and his reign
it's easy enough to see that this
dedication was a religious act but how
was it a political one
the only way theodosius could have any
competition for the throne was if his
sisters had children
through them the theodosian dynasty
could continue and there were plenty of
politically minded suitors eager to
marry a princess and get a claim to the
throne
suzuman wrote to avoid all cause of
jealousy and intrigue she permitted no
man to enter her palace and to remove
any opportunity for the plots of
ambitious men
pulkaria used the strength of her very
public vow of virginity both to ensure
her freedom of action and to secure the
throne for her brother and his offspring
no doubt at his sister's urging
theodosius gave bulgaria the title
empress augusta which increased the
legitimacy of her decisions
in time pulkaria would choose a wife for
her brother the beautiful and
intelligent woman udokia who also
acquired the title empress
there would be two empresses in this
court but only one would bear a child
with the blood of theodosius but that
was in the future
people saw an almost supernatural power
in precarious public vow of virginity in
some ways this probably recalled the
roman vestal virgins who sacrificed
their own fecundity in order that rome
might flourish
so fifth century romans were prepared to
associate virgins with prosperity
we can see this association most clearly
in a victory column that was erected
after 422 to celebrate roman victories
in a war against persia
the fragment of the column's inscription
that remains is telling it praises the
gracious and fortunate emperor
theodosius who was commander-in-chief
but it ends by noting that he was victor
through the vows of his sisters
the virgin sisters praying at the great
palace in constantinople received as
much credit for the victory as
theodosius who was also hanging out
behind the walls of the great palace
without setting foot on the battlefield
once bulkaria took power she organized
her court to be a model of christian
life she brought her brother and sisters
together several times a day to recite
prayers and passages of scripture that
they had memorized
they fasted completely on wednesdays and
fridays which must have seemed shocking
to courtiers who were used to lavish
meals at all times in the palace
bulkaria also insisted that she and her
sisters renounce typical roman vanities
as she called them like cosmetics
luxurious clothing and frivolous
pastimes whatever they were
instead they worked at weaving which
since the origins of rome some 1200
years earlier was considered the only
occupation for a respectable roman woman
pulkaria also found time to educate her
brother in matters of statesmanship she
made sure he knew how to sit and walk in
a grand manner and how to manage his
emotions and to be knowledgeable about
matters of state
she kept him isolated as he learned
these skills and she herself
met with ministers who needed documents
to be signed
she also participated in sessions of the
imperial advisory council
in 414 theodosius installed a bust of
bulkaria in the senate house of
constantinople
this was a shocking statement of her
authority since only men's busts had
been previously displayed there
in 416 theodosius emerged from the
shadows of the residents and took
official rule of the empire
however he was a bookish man
interested more in reading and talking
about ideas
bulkaria always remained at his side and
behind the scenes influencing his
decisions
throughout his reign pulkaria spent
large amounts of money on public
charitable foundations and through these
she became very popular with the people
of constantinople
bulkaria founded churches and
monasteries but she also provided refuge
for beggars and the homeless and
provided generously for their support
from her personal funds
all these accomplishments would be
plenty to rank bulkaria as an impressive
woman but she had an even greater
influence on religion
to understand her impact i need to
explain a bit about churches
and sanctity in the early 5th century
when people went to church they wanted
to put themselves in proximity to some
holiness
and this took the form of sacred relics
body parts of a particularly holy person
when people were in need they prayed to
these holy people for help
thinking that god was so distant that a
holy person whose bones rested in the
church would be closer and more
accessible
in 416 the most powerful relics were
those of the apostles who had known
jesus
in fact emperor constantine in 330 built
a great church in constantinople called
the church of the holy apostles and it
was his intention to gather the relics
of all the apostles to rest in this
church
ultimately the only reputed bones that
came to rest there were those of andrew
luke and timothy and the latter two
aren't strictly speaking apostles
the next best relics were those of
martyrs who had died for the faith
and royal families always wanted to find
these valuable remains
sometime in 420
pulkaria sent a rich gift to the
archbishop of jerusalem and in exchange
the archbishop sent the right arm of the
martyr stephen to the court sometimes
stephen is called the proto-martyr
because he was the first christian to be
killed for his faith by jews rather than
romans
pulkaria found a great chapel for this
holy relic
despite all these new churches dedicated
to holy figures none was dedicated to
the virgin mary
in fact at the beginning of the fifth
century there was only one church
dedicated to mary and it was in ephesus
a city sacred to the virgin artemis
which simply changed its allegiance from
one virgin to another
by contrast in the 12th century almost
all the cathedrals in europe were
dedicated to the virgin mary and more
prayers were said to her than to all
other saints and apostles combined
how did this change take place
it began with a controversy between the
empress bulgaria and a newly appointed
misogynist archbishop named nestorius
at first nestorius worked to restrict
the influence of the noble women of
constantinople he forbade them to
participate in the services of evening
psalms and prayers for the dead and one
prominent woman shouted her objections
to nestorius from the women's gallery of
the church disrupting the service
nestorius responded by attacking even
the influential plucaria
at first he kept his criticism private
he attacked her chastity suggesting she
had enjoyed sexual relations with
several lovers
then he removed her portrait from above
the altar of the royal church and
removed her robe from the altar where it
had served as an altar covering during
the church services
people coming to the church could not
help
but notice his growing attack but then
the conflict became more public
here's what happened
ever since constantine consecrated a new
church in 337 the imperial family
attended at this fine building next to
the royal palace
here was haya irene holy peace
one of the three churches constantine
dedicated to god's attributes peace
wisdom and power
the imperial family both men and women
traditionally entered the sanctuary to
celebrate communion in the presence of
the patriarch of constantinople and his
priests
while the rest of the people were
gathered and worshiped outside the
sanctuary
on easter sunday probably april 15 428
shortly after an astorias took office
the imperial family all dressed in their
silk robes wearing glittering jewels
slowly walked to the entrance of the
sanctuary as the citizens of
constantinople looked on suddenly
archbishop nestoria stepped forward and
boldly barred the way
pool carry a demanded entrance but
nestorius persisted claiming only
priests may walk here
she responded why have i not given birth
to god
he replied you
you have given birth to satan
and then nestorius drove the empress
from the sanctuary
did nestorius pick this public fight
it seems part of his desire to remove
women's presence from the church
and there was already a long history of
monks wanting to avoid any temptation of
female contact
nestorius had been a monk and he seems
to have brought these attitudes to
constantinople
the rhetoric of this fight seems strange
to us
but it was about women's bodies are they
holy or contaminated
bulgaria as a virgin regardless of
nestorius as accusations claimed her
body was holy just like mary's virgin
body
nestorius's background emphasized
women's bodies as temptations beginning
with eve
his accusation of birth of satan
drew from their perceived view of eve as
the origin of original sin of lust i
can't even imagine how shocked and
insulted pulkaria felt at this insult
she guided her brother the emperor
diplomats from all over the world to
knelt before her and she bowed her head
to no one but god in her prayers
theodosius supported nestorius and the
sources don't exactly say why
did he want to reduce his sister's power
or was he just captivated by the
priest's rhetorical flourishes
we don't know
bulkaria was furious but in the next few
days nestorius went even further he
argued let no one call mary theotokos
mother of god she was a human being and
it's impossible that god was born of a
human
nestorius's position hardened even
further as he received pressure from
champions of bulgaria and the virgin
mary he wrote i cannot term him god who
was two and three months old
before i pursue the results of this
theological problem
i should explain briefly just what
mary's position was before this
confrontation at haya irani in 428
before this date the discussions of mary
centered on her flesh as the guarantor
of christ's humanity
these assertions arose in response to
gnostics who believed that jesus was
holy god and his flesh was at best an
illusion
for the gnostics christ's body was not
broken on the cross
he didn't really have a body
in response orthodox church fathers
focused on mary's body as the source of
christ's flesh the pregnancy of mary was
proof of christ's humanity
that said
mary's role was to be limited and was
not to redeem all women
the second century church father
tertullian for example
said once mary had contributed her flesh
in obedience to god's will her role was
done
after christ's birth tertullian wrote
mary became a wife including bearing
future children brothers of jesus
therefore she no longer held any
authority as a dedicated virgin
tertullian introduced the famous attack
on women
you are the devil's gateway through
which death entered the world
even ambrose
a great advocate of virginity warned of
excess veneration of mary he wrote
mary was the temple of god
not the god of the temple
so they walked a fine line between
respect for mary's role and not giving
her too much credit
it's not surprising that no churches
except in ephesus were dedicated to mary
before pulkaria's confrontation with
nestorius
mary's role
probably would have remained ambiguous
with people accepting a position
articulated by the priest
peter chrysologus in the 5th century
when he preached it was best not to pry
too much into this virgin's conceiving
but believe it
4 28 it was too late for that
the battle lines were drawn and pulkaria
was going to vindicate mary
and
herself for a few years after the
disastrous confrontation on easter
sunday the people of constantinople and
the court itself took sides
the emperor theodosius supported his
archbishop nestorius while plucario was
his implacable enemy
and she had acquired a champion of her
own
cyril bishop of alexandria
cyril had gotten into disputes with
nestorius earlier and was ready to gain
precarious support in this fight
finally theodosius called a council
the third ecumenical council to convene
in 431 to settle the question of whether
mary gave birth to god
although theodosius was sure the council
would vindicate nestorius he wanted to
keep some peace in his household so he
accommodated pulkaria and agreed to have
the council held in ephesus
that was his big mistake
ephesus was a magnificent city of marble
on the coast of asia minor on the aegean
sea it was the site of the great temple
of artemis one of the seven wonders of
the ancient world and this city
preserved its respect for virgins as it
became a christian city
in time people believed the virgin mary
lived in ephesus though that's
impossible to prove
at the end of the marble harbor road lay
the church of the virgin mary where the
council was to be held
chaos broke out as soon as the bishops
started to assemble
nestorius's followers wrote to
theodosius
asking to reconvene the council outside
ephesus but it was too late
women of ephesus marched in the streets
supporting the virgin and violence broke
out
even nestorius finally recoiled from the
divisiveness of this issue
in ephesus he said let mary be called
theotokos if you will and let all
disputing cease
but it was too late
crowds in constantinople took up the
cause insisting that the emperor banish
his protege nestorius
theodosius bowed to popular pressure
nestorius was exiled and harmony was
restored to the imperial household
the virgin mary was proclaimed once and
for all the mother of god and pulkaria
was credited with the win
the crowds shouted
mary the virgin had deposed nestorius
many years to bulkaria she it is who
strengthened the faith
many of nestorius's supporters followed
him into exile traveling far as they
looked for a refuge for their beliefs
almost a thousand years later when
travelers from the west entered china
they found nestorian christians
including one of emperor kublai khan's
wives
on christmas day
these christians celebrated the birth of
a human boy who only later took on the
mantle of god
in the roman empire under the guidance
of bulkaria christians believed mary
gave birth to god who had taken on her
flesh in the womb
the council at ephesus was not the final
word on the subject of the nature of the
incarnation
it resolved the question of whether mary
was mother of god
but the remaining question was
how christ's humanity and divinity were
combined
some people said that his divinity was
so powerful that it overwhelmed his
humanity in other words on christmas day
christians celebrated god in the manger
this position emphasized the importance
of god's coming to earth in jesus birth
bulkaria got involved in this
theological controversy as well
precarious supported the position
that christ was both all human
and all divine
why did she care about this
most likely because she saw it as a
continued attack on the virgin mary
if god's divinity obliterated his human
portion that meant that the importance
of mary's human flesh was reduced
and thus the importance of mary
some theologians including most visibly
pope leo in the west advocated the
importance of christ's humanity at the
incarnation
because it meant that his human flesh
was resurrected providing the model for
our human flesh also to rise again
so once the question of the nature of
the incarnation was raised a council was
needed to resolve the issue
bulkaria wanted to gather another
council
but her brother theodosius didn't want
to get involved in yet another
theological conundrum then fate
or god
resolved the dispute on july 26 450
the adoseus fell from his horse and two
days later
he was dead
bulgaria immediately took power
theodosius only child had been a girl
and she was married to emperor
valentinian in the western portion of
the empire
there was no logical air in the east to
prevent any disputes bulkaria chose to
marry
she selected marcion a roman official
who owed his power only to her
she conveyed on him the title of emperor
the first time a woman was able to exert
that power and in return he pledged to
respect her vow of virginity
their marriage was to be a political one
of convenience only never consummated
marcion took over the armies of the
empire and left theology to bulgaria
in 451 at bulkaria's urging marcion
convened a council to meet in calcidon a
city near constantinople that today is a
suburb of istanbul she had enough
control in the capital that she didn't
need ephesus this time
when the council met in calcidon the
empress bulkaria appeared in person to
address the bishops who had traveled
from far away to attend
if nestorius had been shocked to see
bulkaria enter the sanctuary in her own
church
the bishops and council in calcidon must
have been even more shocked to see a
woman address the venerable body of
churchmen
she was too powerful for anyone to
object and not surprisingly the council
agreed with her position on the
incarnation
the virgin mary continued to be exalted
as the council stated a real body was
received from her body and christ
embodied both human and divine natures
fully
the churchmen and council went further
and praised bulgaria many years to the
empress you are the light of orthodoxy
because of this there will be peace
everywhere you have persecuted all
heresies
again not surprisingly everyone did not
agree with the formulation hammered out
at calcodon
those who believe the manger held an
infant that was fully god
left
the modern coptic church of egypt holds
this anti-calcidon position
but that was in the future
pulkaria celebrated her decisive
theological victory
how did pulkaria celebrate her
vindication of the virgin mary
she built churches and in this she
started the shift to a more visible
veneration of the virgin mary
she built three churches dedicated to
the mother of god in constantinople
ephesus would no longer be the only city
that had a church of the virgin
tradition attributes three shrines
calcoprotea blashanai and hodigetria to
bulkaria's foundation
however there was a problem
churches without relics of the virgin
mary would bring no worshipers
what to do
pulkaria wrote to the bishop of
jerusalem ordering him to send the
coffin and shroud of mary to
constantinople
the letter written in the joint names of
bulkaria and her husband marcion claimed
we hear that in jerusalem at the first
and laudable church of the all-holy
theotokos and ever virgin mary in a
village called gethsemane her
life-bearing body was deposited in a
casket it is our wish to bring that
relic here now as a preservative for
this imperial city
the bishop claimed he didn't have the
body though he did not explain why
this correspondence is important because
it is the earliest that implies the
assumption of mary that is that she went
bodily into heaven like jesus leaving no
trace of her body behind
this idea was recorded a century later
by gregory of tours in the west and
slowly became popular
however it was only made official dogma
in the catholic church by pope pius ix
in 1854 and officially declared doctrine
only in 1950.
bulkaria however still needed relics for
her churches
the bishop of jerusalem claimed he only
had the winding sheet in which mary was
buried and he sent that
bulkaria deposited it with much ceremony
at the church in blashanae
tradition held that bulkaria received an
even more valuable relic the icon a
picture painted on wood
called hodegetria which means she who
leads the way
purportedly this icon was painted from
the living model by luke the evangelist
mary has her right hand pointing at the
infant in her arms
as the way of salvation
there is no reliable literary evidence
for the existence of this icon before
the 8th century but by the 11th century
it had become the best known icon of
constantinople paraded through the city
every tuesday to bring blessings to the
people of the city
the fact that later legend attributes
its presence to bulgaria shows how the
virgin empress and the virgin mary were
intertwined each enhancing the
reputation of the other
the veneration of the virgin mary
quickly spread to the western portion of
the empire where theodosius's aunt
galloplacidia had ruled as regent for
her son valentinian and still exerted
influence over her son
pope sixtus iii who had been consecrated
in july 432 commissioned a new church to
commemorate mary's newly confirmed
status of mother of god
and likely to please his empress
this church santa maria maggiore was the
first basilica to be dedicated to mary
in the west
rome needed a relic to install in mary's
new church and they brought what was
said to be a piece of wood from the baby
jesus's crib
thus santa maria maggiore became not
only a church that celebrated mary but
also focused on motherhood and the
nativity a holiday that was only
beginning to be celebrated in the 5th
century
bulgaria died in 453 only a couple of
years after her great victory at
calcedon and she was named a saint for
her work on behalf of the growing church
but the virgin empress's impact on
christian worship continued in the 12th
century almost all the cathedrals in
christendom were dedicated to the virgin
and she was no longer seen as a poor
modest jewish girl who bowed her head to
god's will
instead as the 13th century mosaic and
santa maria madiori shows she rules as
queen of heaven next to her son
if the empress bulgaria could have seen
these portrayals she would have been
thrilled
even a misogynist archbishop could not
keep the queen of heaven out of the
finest sanctuaries of the churches in
christendom
you